in case you missed it there's Secret
Wars there's proxy wars but did you know
there's also nobody gives a [ __ ] war
Somalia you'll know it from those black
villain vs. white hero Hollywood
classics like Black Hawk Down or Captain
Phillips you're probably less familiar
with the current Washington production a
wave of deadly air strikes the US has
been bombing al-shabaab Islamic
militants there on and off since 2007
it's proved a minor inconvenience to the
al Qaeda fanboys who continue to go
about their business pretty much
unimpeded so the hundreds of thousands
of civilians forced to flee their homes
have found themselves caught between the
usual lunatic terrorists and anonymous
killing machines Somalia just isn't on
people's radars we know about the big
Wars the glamour conflicts Afghanistan
Syria and the support acts like Yemen
which doesn't get much attention but yes
still kind of know it's happening but
Somalia a godforsaken place located
somewhere here is just not making the
headlines so the US military has found
itself in quite the sweet spot it's got
a surplus of killer drones that are no
longer needed in Syria and a nice sandy
war zone then no one is paying attention
to guess what they decided air strikes
but Somalia they've surged in the past
six months dozens of militants have been
killed and absolutely no civilians says
the military aid agencies and locals say
that actually civilians have been killed
but they would say that wouldn't name
Somalia is a straightforward water fight
there is an obvious bad guy the drones
are doing all the heavy lifting and it's
all being conducted by us Africa Command
in Stuttgart a city many of you will
know isn't actually in Africa a former
US government official described Somalia
as a massive war on auto-pilot
bombing campaigns against poor countries
have not worked out well in the past but
then again if no one is paying attention
what do they have to lose I just can't
figure out
they care so much
[Music]